media controlling the narrative is a
really hot topic you mentioned Elon Musk
so let's get into it why do you think
Elon Musk is going to turn Twitter into
a trillion dollar company uh okay so
let's go through a few different things
number one I think Tick Tock is going to
be banned in the next two to four years
a president is going to ban Tick Tock
and that's going to happen in no time
when they do there's going to be a major
uproar Biden would never do it but I
think a Republican president will ban
Tick-Tock tick tock's already banned by
uh um India who banned 100 different
apps and the next president will do it
who's on the Republican side if a Joe
Rogan who's known as a Centrist is
saying the Red Wave is coming like The
Shining elevator opening up and he is
not a fan of tick tock just in the next
few years tick tock's going to be banned
when that happens that's a lot of users
that have to find a home and they're not
going to go to Facebook because Facebook
has totally screwed it up they lost
valuation of uh this year alone when I
don't know if you know how much they
lost this year in valuation he lost 100
billion dollars of net worth but
Facebook valuation has dropped 800
billion dollars insane on how much
valuation that is so why did they lose
that kind of valuation he's not trusted
unfortunately it's going to hurt him
obviously Facebook's not trusted they're
you know throttling Instagram on who
gets to see your post they do it with
Facebook as well so the audience from
there it's not like Tick Tock audience
is going to go to Instagram some of it
will but they're going to go to Twitter
number two I think elon's going to turn
Twitter into the next WeChat if you're
familiar with WeChat in China WeChat is
one app that does it all you know you
can do Uber Lyft uh food you know
content creation texting WhatsApp
everything under one app is WeChat
WeChat has around 900 million users it's
a trillion auto company I think Elon
will do that here next thing I think
Elon will do is Elon will figure out
with this Eight dollar a month
memberships that he's doing that people
are complaining about but I think he's
gonna have a 29.99 99.99 199 and we're
going to pay for it because LinkedIn as
much as people about it linkedin's
lowest one is 99 and it goes all the way
up to 100 29.99 no one's ever complained
about LinkedIn you got to figure out a
way to make money he'll do that he's
going to create the app
to allow content creators to come to
make money so he's going to have a form
of a YouTube on Twitter which by the way
when he does that it's going to be quite
scary when he does that next one he's
bringing his Engineers from Tesla he
brought 50 Engineers from Tesla and to
look at the technology so he's going to
make the technology better in Twitter
and that's a no-brainer when he brings
Tesla's Engineers he brought Tesla's
head of HR they're going to hire the
best of the best to clean house with
Twitter obviously half the company is
getting laid off and he'll bring the
right people in I think he's going to
probably leave California move the
headquarters to most likely Austin or
Florida I don't think he'll stay there
and then the freedom of you know freedom
of speech type of people who feel
comfortable right now talking no one's
feeling uncomfortable talking on Twitter
yeah you're pretty comfortable I mean
yesterday somebody got uh the platform
was suspended I don't know if you saw
that with cat Kathy what she did but she
was impersonating Kim so she's trying to
troll he's like nope you're off if you
choose to adjust you can come back and
then at the end today why I think it'll
be a trillion out of companies because
the guy that's running it Elon um I
believe he's gonna I try to get some
money to get into the company Kathy Wood
from Arc was able to get some investment
into Twitter but if you invest with ARC
today uh per dollar you put only 12
cents goes into the Twitter stock so
we're trying to figure out a way to get
into the Twitter although it's very very
hard Morgan Stanley's not doing it
Goldman's not doing it but I'm just a
big believer what's going to happen by
the way I could be completely wronged
and it completely flops and it does
nothing and I'm comfortable with that
but if I'm a betting man I would bet on
Twitter being a trillion Auto Company my
only issue with Elon Musk evolving the
company's turning into some kind of
WeChat like he said is that it would
almost become unusable and saturated a
bit like Facebook Facebook they tried to
do that I know obviously there are other
reasons why Mark Zuckerberg failed but
I feel like it might become saturated
difficult to use and I think one of the
reasons Twitter was so successful is
because it just remained one thing yeah
do you not think it could potentially
become unusable let me ask you a
question when's the last time you
tweeted a complaint or a concern at Mark
Zuckerberg and he responded back never
well I don't think he's on Twitter
actually well the point is just never
period right but when's the last time
you hear a number of stories where Elon
responds back wanting feedback and ideas
on how to make it better that's the
difference this is this is not a regular
guy Elan is a guy that knows what he
wants but I also believe elon's a guy
that's a what do you think like hey
audience what do you think should I
bring Vine back what do you think uh to
make Twitter the next app and then Mr
Beast says whatever you do don't do what
anybody else can duplicate and copy so
this is what do you think guy with his
own identity and signature to the
product it's a different operator very
very different this is not just a very
very smart guy this is a very very very
smart guy that understands she still
needs you that's the difference so some
of these guys are like ah you're going
to do it no matter what whether you like
it or not I don't think that's enough
yeah that's a great Point yeah I see I'm
replying to people all the time on
Twitter so yeah and that's a great place
where 300 billion dollars we're playing
at least this person will be like who do
you think you know do you know who I am
why would I respond like no okay cool
yeah it's amazing
thank you